hallo en welkom iedereen dit is
actieve inferentie gast stream 28.1 het is
14 oktober 2022.
vandaag gaan we luisteren naar en
discussiëren over de rationaliteit van heropvatting door
Giovanni Rolla dus Giovanni
heel erg bedankt voor je deelname heel erg
benieuwd naar deze presentatie en
discussie dus op naar  dank u
dank u dan was het een genoegen
om uw uitnodiging een paar
maanden geleden te ontvangen en ik ben verheugd hier
te zijn om deze gelegenheid te hebben om mijn werk te bespreken
eh ik zal uw verzoek
um onze suggestie besparen
paper die ik een paar jaar geleden schreef
en uh terwijl we achter de schermen aan het praten waren
Ik heb ik een paar
keer van gedachten veranderd en ik ga dit
tijdens de presentatie duidelijk maken sinds
ik die paper publiceerde, maar het is een
genoegen  niettemin om de kans
te hebben om deze video hier te presenteren en uh
om het met de wereld te delen, dus ik ben erg
blij
uh dus we zullen het hebben over het
herontdekken van rationaliteit en dit is
dit is het
reisschema  Ik dacht erover
om je te presenteren, dus eerst zal ik
het hebben over rationaliteit en
inhoudloze cognitie, dan zal ik
mijn visie presenteren die ik radicaal
inactieve rationaliteit en veiligheidswoorden noemde
over keuzevrijheid en bekwame interactie
en redenering en rationaliteit ze zijn
close met een paar  van bezwaren, de
eerste is dat
wat ik hier ook ben, een echte
liberaal is op een manier die overdreven liberaal is, het
omvat te veel en de tweede
tegenwerping waarvan ik denk dat
die voor jou het meest interessant is, is of
het effect compatibel is  met voorspellend
proces in onze voorspellende codering
die natuurlijk in de faciliteit is in de
buurt van de twee auto's in het midden
om actieve invloed uit te oefenen,
dus
hier is het
sorry mijn eerste gedachten over de kwestie zijn
dat traditioneel de zeer
uh-orthodoxe  heb zicht op rationaliteit
uh gaat ervan uit
dat voor zover ik weet het als een aanname is dat
rationaliteit in hun redenering moet zijn
Ik geloof dat B in een
actie a rationeel is als en alleen als
er de redenering is die
de Bure zo onderschrijft en natuurlijk is het gewoon
geen redenering die de redeneringsvraag
moet krijgen met bepaalde
formele maatstaven zoals uh klassieke
logica of waarschijnlijkheidsredenering of
heuristieken die zo rationeel geloven en handelen
volgens deze traditionele
film
vereisen dat aan bepaalde formele normen wordt voldaan
en dit, zoals ik al zei, lijkt mij
grotendeels een veronderstelling te zijn over wat het
betekent om rationeel te zijn over het definiëren van
rationaliteit in termen van redeneren,
dus als rationaliteit redeneren vereist
en  als redeneren de evaluatie
van overtuigingen tegen bepaalde formele
maatstaven inhoudt, dan impliceert rationaliteit
inhoud voor cognitie
waar inhoud naar mijn mening minimaal is
met nauwkeurigheid voorwaarden in
staat zijn om
goed of fout te zijn of in of in op een meer
gewichtiger idee waar of onwaar, dus
de  idee hier is dat rationaliteit
noodzakelijkerwijs inhoud omvat, het omvat
overtuigingen  redenering en de vergelijking of
sorry
om nu
één software-update bij te werken Het spijt me dat er hier
een pop-up in mijn venster was, dus
dat zou zijn, ik denk dat het de
standaardvisie op rationaliteit is
en
als het zo is dat rationaliteit noodzakelijkerwijs
inhoudt  inhoud het past goed
bij klassiek cognitivisme of
cognitivisme in het algemeen,
wat de opvatting is dat combinatie
noodzakelijkerwijs representatieve
inhoud omvat, op zijn minst voor een
cognitivist natuurlijk kan het ook
een conceptuele inhoud omvatten, maar op zijn
minst representatieve inhoud die
nauwkeurigheidscondities,
maar deze klassieke visie is niet zo goed
dat het niet zo goed past bij
radicaal inactieve en belichaamde
cognitie
die ik hier uh denk niet
specifiek aan radicaal en activisme van
Goodwin Maine in de recente boeken, maar ik
denk dat het ook andere uitdaagt  opvattingen
die niet als radicaal en actief worden gepresenteerd,
maar die natuurlijk enkele
kernpachters delen met radicale en actieve
we zouden ze uh radicaal belichaamde
opvattingen van cognities kunnen noemen, zoals
eh met de opvattingen gepresenteerd door Ezekiel
Powell of Berman
zintuiglijk modelleven, je hebt ook
Gallagher's verscheidenheid aan inactivisme in zijn
boek uit 2017 en ook de ik bedoel de visie
van Tony Kimero in zijn  2009 boek over
ecologische psychologie en dynamische
systemen ze hebben allemaal dezelfde huurders
en hier ben ik Ik weet dat dit zeer
controversieel is, maar ik behandel die
opvattingen als radicaal belichaamde opvattingen over
cognitie en ik ben specifiek
gericht op radicale en actieve opvattingen over
koken
ze zeggen allemaal dat niet de herkenning
representatief inhoudsvol is, wat in
zekere zin wil zeggen dat we kunnen denken aan
basisinhoudloze vormen van cognitie
of een inhoudloos niveau basisniveau van
herkenning
dat ontstaat door de actieve
verkenning van iemands omgeving en
voorbij radicaal en activisme door  wat we
bedoelen,
dit zou kunnen zijn dat dit idee kan worden
verzilverd in termen van het beheersen van sensorische motorische activiteiten
, een kwestie van weten  -hoe
het weten hoe je met je omgeving om moet gaan in
plaats van te weten dat
dingen zo en zo om je heen zijn, dus dit
is heel duidelijk wat de Paulo en
collega's en uh kimero bijvoorbeeld
in hun boeken doen uh radicaal en activisme
heeft een zekere neiging tot scheeftrekking  zintuiglijke
modelovereenkomsten zintuiglijke modelschema's
enz.
En uh,
maar recente ontwikkelingen hebben denk ik
opgenomen dat dus dit is het
gebruik van de essentie van dit idee,
dus als we radicale belichaamde opvattingen
over herkauwen of radicaal en activisme combineren
en de klassieke brandstof op  rationaliteit
wat we hebben is iets dat Angle
als volgt heeft beschreven
een activisme is de opvatting dat cognitie
is gebaseerd op een gebed rationeel
begrip van de wereld dat is gebaseerd
op sensorische motorische verwerving van de
werkelijke situatie
en hij legt deze uit uh dit idee van
pre-  rationeel begrip
door
um
door de ideeën van melopentin
Heidegger volgens wie de relatie
tot de wereld slechts één kan zijn die wortelt in
p  inactieven in acteren en
oefenen intern wordt gemedieerd door
het lichaam, dus wat hier impliciet lijkt te zijn
, is dat in tegenstelling tot acteren en oefenen,
rationaliteit
eigenlijk niet iets is dat niet op een heel
basaal combinatieniveau is, dus dit is
wat er gebeurde toen we
ruimte maken voor een basisniveau van cognitie dat
geworteld is in actief en in de praktijk en het
scheiden van hogere
combinatieniveaus dat zij meestal de
locus zijn, de gelukkige klassieker van rationaliteit,
dus
het idee in samenvatting is dat
controversiële kennis of basiskennis
dat wat naar voren komt door zintuiglijke  motorische
bezigheden zijn niet rationeel,
dus zintuiglijke moderne bezigheden, hoe
vruchtbaar ze ook kunnen zijn, kunnen niet
worden geëvalueerd vanuit het oogpunt van
rationaliteit alleen inhoud voor cognitie
combinatie op hoog niveau kan een rationele
definitie zijn die wordt uitgedrukt in
bijvoorbeeld overtuigingen en recentelijk
en goed dit is iets  dat
ik niet op het papier heb aangestipt, maar het
was mijn impliciete motivatie om d  eel met
dit onderwerp
als iemand die uit de filosofie van
de geest komt is het idee van de mythe van het
gegeven tenminste een versie
ervan leek me op dat moment en uh ik was
correct overgehaald door een recensent om
het onderwerp niet aan te raken  het was erg
ingewikkeld in mijn eerste presentatie,
maar het lijkt mij dat als we
basisherkenning scheiden van een rationele gedachte
en actie en we niet naar
de
bron wijzen, er geen, ik bedoel, kruising is
tussen deze twee niveaus, het lijkt alsof
radicaal en activisme en  uh soortgelijke
opvattingen zouden worden gecommitteerd aan de mythe van
het gegeven dat niet populair is door verkopers en
moderaties door McDowell als een probleem voor
heerszuchtige gebieden van mijn geest,
dus het lijkt erop dat dit volgens mij een
[muziek]
een filosofisch interessant probleem is,
maar het is niet iets dat is  uh op de
voorgrond van de krant was het mijn
impliciete motivatie hier om uit te leggen
hoe we het inhoudloze of
basale niveau van cognitie kunnen combineren door middel van zintuiglijke
moderne bezigheden met ratio  als
je dat niet kunt, lijkt het erop dat er een
bepaald gegeven is dat
niet volledig wordt uitgelegd in ons beeld
van de geest, dus dit is iets wat ik
wilde. Ik wil nog steeds proberen
dit deze intuïtie duidelijker te onderzoeken, maar ik heb
Ik heb dit niet aangeroerd, maar ik denk dat er iets is in de
richting van wat ik vandaag zal laten zien
is. Ik denk dat het een manier is om
deze beschuldiging uit te drukken dat we toegewijd zijn
aan de mythe van het gegeven,
dus hoe kunnen we rationaliteit herontdekken,
bedoel ik  Ik denk dat om dat
probleem te vermijden en het idee te vermijden dat we
twee niveaus hebben die volledig van
elkaar gescheiden zijn, waar de Hogere
de locus klassieke rationaliteit is en
wat er nog meer onder zit, het niet rationeel is. Ik
denk dat het idee is om rationaliteit te verwerpen
het  moet worden gedefinieerd of het
brengt noodzakelijkerwijs redeneren met zich mee
hoeft niet nog steeds te worden bedacht, maar
dan wordt de uitdaging om een
positief
voorstel te doen van wat rationaliteit is, zo niet
redeneren en hier is Susan H  urley in een
paper dat mijn kennis de enige is
die
over dit onderwerp gaat en ik denk dat ze destijds
ook bezorgd was over de mythe
van het gegeven trouwens en hij is een
lang citaat van hier phenomide me
lezend dat het die rationaliteit is  zou kunnen
voortkomen uit een complex systeem van de
gecentraliseerde hiërarchie relaties van
remming faciliteren en coördinatie
tussen verschillende horizontale lagen die elk een
dynamische en
omgevingsgerichte rationaliteit zijn, opgevat in
horizontale of modulaire termen uh ik weet niet
of ze deze
terminologie moet gebruiken, maar  hoe dan ook, zo
koos ze ervoor om het uit te drukken is duurzaam
gerelateerd aan de omgeving het hangt niet
alleen af ​​van interne procedures die
bemiddelen tussen input en output zoals
inhoud, hetzij voor het organisme als
geheel of voor een verticaal begrensde
centrale cognitieve module, het
hangt er eerder van af  complexe relaties tussen
toegewijde wereld met lagen die
toezicht houden op en reageren op specifieke aspecten
van de n  natuurlijke en sociale omgeving
en van het neurale netwerk en
hun feedback op hun antwoorden verminderen. Dit
is voor zover ik weet het eerste geval van
iemand die aan de inactieve benadering werkt
op een manier die
duidelijk vaker
wordt geassocieerd met het werk van
avano, die ook een activist is, maar
in een andere benadering dan radicaal en
activisme en hier is de vroegste
en voor zover ik weet voordat ik dat artikel schreef,
is dat het duidelijkste
uh-voorstel van rationaliteit dat
in de moedertaal is herontworpen, maar het is
niet iets dat uh
na haar publicatie aan populariteit heeft gewonnen  mijn kennis
eigenlijk heb ik sindsdien niet veel gezien
en om samen te vatten het idee is dat we
de verklarende focus moeten veranderen
, namelijk rationaliteit wordt niet uitsluitend
gezien als een inhoud die
capaciteit in dit voorstel inhoudt het is gesitueerd
of wereld betrokken in grotere werelden
en is het radicaal belichaamd, dan
hangt het af van lichamelijke morfologie en actie
en hoe het organisme zich bevindt en
handelt  s in die omgeving zal het
idee minimaal dood zijn, dus dit is wat ik noem
radicaal inactieve rationaliteit
is eh in een zeer
losse definitie tot nu toe is dat een Aziaat
rationeel handelt voor zover de
mens een bekwame interactie met
haar omgeving onderhoudt en haar
cognitieve vaardigheden coördineert  afhankelijk van de
omgevingsomstandigheden van beperkingen
en vaste stations en natuurlijk
vereist dit soms aanpassing aan
onvoorziene omstandigheden. De
kernintuïtie is dit
en het is interessant om dit
idee van radicale en actieve rationaliteit te vergelijken
met een ander idee van Susan Hurley in
een tekst uit 2003  ze zegt
redenen om te handelen dat ze stelt
dat redenen om te handelen contextgebonden kunnen zijn
, waar ze argumenteert tegen de
algemene beperking van Gareth Evans
en dit is de verdediging van het idee van
eilanden van praktische rationaliteit,
dus behandelt ze rationaliteit nog steeds als in
wezen iets dat verband houdt  om
hier te redeneren, maar dit soort
redeneren is beperkt  d door praktische
context, dus dit is een zeer vooruitstrevende
visie in vergelijking met de traditionele
visie waar ik het in het begin over had,
maar nog steeds conservatiever dan wat
ik hier probeer te ontwikkelen,
dus iets anders waarvan ik denk dat het
daar de voorgrond van dit moet zijn  voorstel
is dat rationaliteit agency en
autonomie impliceert omdat van iets of alleen
iets dat een organisme doet kan worden
gezegd dat het rationeel goed is,
dus om deze te gebruiken uh de ideeën van het
autonome en activistische kamp en van
de theorie van hoe spelers
autonome systemen zijn zoals  een Roomba
kan niet rationeel zijn omdat het geen
agent is, het is niet de auteur van zijn eigen
gedrag het is ontworpen door externe
agenten om op een bepaalde manier te werken, dus het
is strikt genomen geen natie,
dus daar zou ik de grens trekken van waar
goed  je kan niet het heeft geen zin om
rationaliteit toe te schrijven aan bijvoorbeeld een Roomba
en
hiervoor
gebruik ik de begrippen autonomie en
aanpassingsvermogen de DiPaolo en anderen die je
hebt  Zo ook het recente boekbeeld het
vier zintuiglijke modelleven en dat beroemde
papier uit de kom uit 2005 waar hij
praat over de aanpassingsvermogen
om zijn zeer algemene beperkingen
op te leggen aan wat het betekent om Russisch te zijn,
zodat autonome systemen daardoor worden
opgevat als precaire netwerken een
precair netwerk van processen omdat
organisatie en fysieke grenzen worden
geproduceerd door het systeem zelf, het
systeem handhaaft voortdurend zijn eigen
levensvatbaarheid, wat
bekend staat als zingeving, waarbij het
systeem de
omgevingscondities verkent die
gunstig zijn voor zijn zelfonderhoud en
vermijdt degenen die er schadelijk voor zijn
,
dus dit is hoe ik begrijp dat
het in het algemeen de
emotionele beperking is van een rationeel wezen
dat het een autonoom systeem moet zijn
en het interessante hier is dat
het concept van aanpassingsvermogen dat Paulo maar
naar voren is dat het vermogen van een
organisme om zijn toestand van zelfproductie te verbeteren door middel van
h interne
structurele veranderingen,
dus het gaat om het bewaken en
reguleren van interne veranderingen
om de best beschikbare manier van handelen te selecteren.
Ik denk dat het een ander
interessant concept is om over na te denken
om dit idee van een radicaal
inactieve notie van rationaliteit op te nemen die
is niet noodzakelijk toegewijd aan
redeneren en inhoud,
dus agency wordt gerealiseerd door de
uitoefening van gesitueerde vermogens die
veranderingen binnen het organisme bevorderen in
overeenstemming met
omgevingsbeperkingen en onderstations,
wat betekent dat hoe goed een organisme
zich aanpast om bekwaam om te gaan
met zijn omgeving een maatstaf is  van of
een indicatie van zijn rationaliteit,
hoe rationeler een organisme is, hoe
geschikter het is om met zijn omgeving om te gaan
en we hebben de omstandigheden voorzien
en door dit te doen verbetert het organisme
de voortdurende uitwisselingen tussen zichzelf
en de omgeving
die cruciaal is voor zijn overleving en  het
is een zeer
genaturaliseerde manier van denken over
rationaliteit  is meestal het vermogen om
veranderingen te verbeteren om te overleven
dit is
het algemene idee hier,
dus zoals ik al eerder zei hoe zit het met redeneren
ik
wil ik niet noodzakelijkerwijs rationaliteit
toepassen met redeneren en dit is
waar radicaal inactieve
rationaliteit over gaat, maar ik  wil redeneren niet uitsluiten
als een voormalige rationele
combinatie, dus wat ik zeg is dat
het niet wordt gedefinieerd door redeneren, maar het is
niet uh het sluit redeneren niet uit,
redeneren zou volgens mij worden gezien als
een speciale of specifieke vorm van
rationeel handelen  een die exclusief is voor onze
kennis aan mensen,
maar het is niet het bepalende kenmerk van
rationaliteit,
dus hiervoor ik uh om
dit idee uit te leggen, herinner ik me hoe Hutu en
Saturn tussen het papier in het meest recente
boek van utani ze uitleggen de  opkomst
van hoge herkenning het idee is
dat de mogelijkheid om deel te nemen aan inhoud voor
cognitie uiteindelijk afhangt van
sociaal-cultureel ingebed zijn
waar inhoud volledige cognitie voortkwam
uit soc  Als
een individu deelneemt aan sociaal-
culturele praktijken
, accepteren ze meer oude cognitieve
vaardigheden om met symbolen om te gaan en door dit te
doen, komen ze
in een lang proces van inculturatie
terecht dat
ze in staat zijn om deel te nemen met uh
symbolische coördinatie die niet
intern is  representatie specifiek omdat
het publiekelijk beschikbaar is, het zijn geen mentale
representaties in de traditionele zin,
maar het heeft de kenmerken van symbolische
cognitie zonder de toewijding aan
interne representatie of mentale
representaties,
dus rationeel handelen in de meest algemene
zin is het idee dat het bekwame
gedrag van een  organisme is in uh is is
het bekwame gedrag van een organisme
in zijn omgeving het hangt af van de
coördinatie van belichaamde vermogens
terwijl redeneren als alles
goed gaat natuurlijk wordt begrepen als inhoud
voor rationaliteit voor mijn specifieke wijze van
rationaliteit redeneren is het bekwame
gedrag van een  organisme in een sociaal-
culturele omgeving  omgeving,
wat natuurlijk een specifieker aspect van onze
omgeving is en het hangt af van
de coördinatie van zo'n cultureel
gebaseerde of inhoud met vaardigheden
die recenter zijn op de menselijke
fylogenetische schaal,
zo goed dit is het grootste van het
idee dit is het  het ik denk
uh het propositieve deel en hier zijn
de bezwaren waar ik het over wilde hebben, de
eerste is dat het een zeer liberale
kijk is, het is heel
eh het is goed, het omvat te
veel zou je zeggen, want als rationeel handelen
neerkomt op de coördinatie  van
cognitieve vaardigheden, dan is rationaliteit
iets geleidelijks, want een organisme
zou min of meer bedreven kunnen zijn in zijn
omgevingsinteracties
en de afwijzing gaat volgens
radicaal inactieve rationaliteit.
ben eh nou iemand zou rationele
en actieve radicale en actieve
rationaliteiten kunnen zingen voor liberaal en dit is  een
bezwaar dat ik persoonlijk heb gehoord
en ik heb het zo hard gehouden omdat ik
het erg vind, het is een heel goede manier
om het te zeggen, zelfs nagels zijn rationeel over
deze mening en dat waarvan ik moet zeggen
dat ik bereid ben te kopen  de portemonnee
eh ja, het is liberaler dan
traditionele opvattingen natuurlijk is het de
bedoeling dat het zo is, maar ik denk niet dat
dit per se een probleem is, wat ik denk dat
het positieve is hier is dat het
een verschil in graad behoudt dat
mensen zijn  veel rationeler dan andere
dieren, simpelweg omdat we in staat zijn
om een ​​breed scala aan acties uit te voeren in een
breed scala aan dynamische omstandigheden
die veel verder gaan dan alle andere dieren
waarvan we ons bewust zijn,
dus om terug te komen op het voorbeeld van
deze nagel kan deze nagel  een paar complexe
acties uitvoeren kan van het ene punt naar het
andere gaan het kan voedsel en
onderdak zoeken enzovoort, maar ze hebben
een kritische beperkte reeks vaardigheden als
je deze spijker omringt met het zuiden
bijvoorbeeld is het gedoemd om te sterven door
de retortatie en mensen aan de andere
kant zijn ze veel adaptiever en
kunnen ze dynamisch omgaan met veel
onvoorziene omstandigheden, dus
in mijn antwoord op dat bezwaar is dat
ja,
nou ja, het is heel liberaal, maar dat is
niet het probleem het probleem zou zijn als
dat  het is als er ruimte was voor een
gradueel verschil tussen hoe dieren
omgaan met hun
omgeving, en dit is het andere object
bezwaar waarvan ik denk dat het misschien
degene is die je het meest interesseert, dan
weet je dat het de 12 voorspellende verwerking is
lijkt de hele weg gevolgtrekkingen en inhoud te impliceren,
maar in eerste instantie moet ik u en
de kijkers waarschuwen dat
op het moment dat ik dit schreef, dit
artikel veel optimistischer was over deze
mogelijkheid om een ​​activisme te combineren met
voorspellende codering of voorspellende
verwerking en uh  Ik denk dat er
hier belangrijke punten zijn, maar er is een
recente paper van Olu en Evan Thompson
en Randy Beer waar ze, eh,
een kritische beoordeling geven van eh.  e
de de pogingen om voornamelijk
het vrije-energieprincipe en
um
inactieve en
autobiografische theorieën te combineren, dus ik ben nu
grotendeels overtuigd door de argumenten, maar ik
denk dat er hier enkele
interessante vergelijkingspunten zijn, toch
zo voorspellend proces in onze voorspellende
code en uh bij de  tijd dat ik aan het schrijven was
en tot op de dag van vandaag is het een rage in
de cognitieve wetenschappen. Ik denk dat je kunt
zeggen dat het klonk dat snoep
een van de belangrijkste paradigma's werd die er zijn, dus
het is interessant om te zien of
het goed past bij wat ik  Ik heb het over
en in deze kijkers weet je dat
concurrentie wordt begrepen als een proces
van foutminimalisatie dat plaatsvindt in
bidirectionele nauwe hiërarchieën,
dus
je hebt de generatie van interne
modellen voor de activiteit van lagere lagen
die anticipeert op de distale oorzaken van
sinistere stimuli, wat een  top-down
proces en het minimaliseren van
discrepantie tussen voorspelling en
huidig ​​stimulussignaal door
um de bezetting van priors die  is een
bodem van het proces,
dus hier is natuurlijk actieve gevolgtrekking
die wordt begrepen door bijvoorbeeld in
een informele, je kent formele termen door
Clark, dat een organisme zijn sensoren beweegt
op manieren die erop neerkomen dat we actief zoeken in
onze generatie en de zintuiglijke
gevolgen genereren dat ze nogal  hun
hersenen verwachten dat
dit een manier is om actieve
beïnvloeding van zeer formele termen te begrijpen, maar ik
denk dat de klus geklaard is,
dus de hersenen leiden de verwachte
bron van ontvangen stimuli af als dat zo is,
het lijkt erop dat er een
probleem is met wat ik ben  praten over
dus de hem stemmen lezing van voorspellende
verwerking die gebruik maakt van de
productbias en inferentierecht zegt
bijvoorbeeld dat het proces van
percepties gescheiden is van
rationeel breder vooringenomenheid proces van
prolificatie en context top-down
effecten Ik voelde dat elk tussenliggend
niveau van  het verwerken hiervan heeft mijn
aandacht getrokken op de manier waarop Clark ook de hele tijd
over rationaliteit praat,
maar het is een...  Een inferentiële vorm van
rationaliteit
en doordringende beïnvloedingsredenen lijkt
een niet-persistente inhoud te impliceren
en dan lijkt voorspellende verwerking
onverenigbaar met radicaal inactieve
rationaliteit, maar er is uh op het moment dat die er
was en ik denk dat we nog steeds kunnen argumenteren in
verschillende van de er is geen
non  -aambeien en het lezen van
voorspellende verwerking
die bijvoorbeeld een eerste stap gebruikt,
zou zijn om een ​​​​deflatoir gevoel van
voorspelling te gebruiken dat het begrijpen van cameo in een
korte paper uit 2013 maar vierde waar
de waarden van twee of meer variabelen
covariabel zijn of betrouwbaar zijn, zodat de
waarde van 1 stelt de waarnemer in staat om
de waarde van een ander af te leiden en
hier gebeurt de gevolgtrekking op het
niveau van de waarneming, niet op een verre
variabele leidt de waarde van
een ander af, dus het idee zou zijn dat ik denk
dat inhoud in het oog van  de
toeschouwer de persoon die interpreteert hoe
de selectie van censuur die we plaatsen
interne voorspellingen benadert die hier worden
begrepen in t  De inflatoire zin
kan het in inferentiële en bevooroordeelde
termen beschrijven, dus dit is hoe ik bijvoorbeeld
het idee over 4000 van Bruno-
paper zie, dat als ik me niet vergis de
titel zoiets is als het brein is
geen wetenschapper en het argument is in  deze
algemene richting
die we projecteren, hoe
wetenschappers hersenactiviteit interpreteren als een
kenmerk van de hersenen zelf alsof
het dit meer
uh robuuste of zwaardere zintuig voorspelt en afleidt,
dus wat ik hier probeer te zeggen is dat
actieve gevolgtrekking dan gebruik ik dubbele  en
zeg dubbel, vergat de naam hiervan in het
Engels sorry
um het is niet uh de letterlijke betekenis van
gevolgtrekking hier volgens radicaal
inactief
uh rationaliteit is dat ongewapend voor de
efficiëntie van co-georiënteerd gedrag de
agent op bepaalde manieren moet handelen
om zijn  zijn of haar staten komen
efficiënter tot bloei, minder kostbaar,
dit impliceert niet de meer controversiële
bewering dat de generatieve modellen
zelf voorspellende inferenties vertonen en uitvoeren
es dit is een zeer
deflatoire lezing van voorspellende
verwerking om deze
combinatie te voorzien van radicale en actieve
rationaliteit
en hier is een aftrap in een paper uit
per model volgt niet dat een
organisme een intern
representatief model van zijn niche heeft in
die zin dat het  is dit model dat dat het
cognitieve werk is als je wilt, in plaats daarvan een
organisme is een model dat de causale
en statistische regelmatigheden weerspiegelen in een
bepaalde omgeving die een
fenotype weerspiegelt dat een model is
en nou,
dit heeft betrekking op iets dat onlangs
uh, mijn collega meldt en ik  hebben
gesproken over het idee van hoe organismen
een wereld voortbrengen volgens een
activisme dat het idee is dat het organisme
en de omgeving
historisch bepaald worden genoemd, dus
op de genetische stroomschaal zou dit kunnen
worden verklaard door het idee van
nicheconstructie het idee dat ooit  een
organisme is actief in zijn omgeving, het
bevordert veranderingen die, als ze stabiel
genoeg zijn,  ze kunnen worden geërfd door zijn
nakomelingen en deze veranderingen zorgen voor nieuwe
evolutionaire druk op de pers
die zijn evolutionaire pad leiden.
dat rationeel handelen betekent
een bekwaam engagement met de
omgeving bereiken door in zekere zin voorspelling
en hun minimalisering te
accepteren.
zinloze voorspelling en hun minimalisering
omvatten de selectie van input en de
coördinatie van interabilities in de omgang met de
wereld, wat
precies de belangrijkste claim is van radicale en
actieve persoonlijkheid, dus ik denk in die
mate dat voorspellende verwerking
niet uh een vijand zou zijn  dan een leugen
van dit idee in plaats van uh
aankomst maar van c  er zijn andere
compatibiliteitsproblemen die ik hier niet heb
besproken, maar dat is
alles waar ik aan heb gedacht voor vandaag bedankt
geweldig bedankt heel
erg goed
cool erg interessant
voor degenen die live kijken,
voel je vrij om  schrijf eventuele vragen Ik zal
mijn aantekeningen verzamelen en laten we beginnen met de
discussie
oke eerst gewoon nogmaals bedankt voor het
gesprek
wat dacht je van een beetje context over hoe
je deze vragen in
je huidige functie kwam stellen en hoe je
interesses op dit gebied zich ontwikkelden omdat
er  zoveel interessante ideeën en ik
wilde gewoon meer weten over hoe
je tot dit frame kwam en je punt scherper maakte
oke dank je dat is een goede
vraag, want het is niet vaak dat je
deze achtergrond kunt verkennen,
het is belangrijk dus uh ik was op het moment dat ik
ik dacht dat ik mijn proefschrift aan
het schrijven was, het was misschien 2007 of zoiets en uh
ik pleitte voor het idee dat
rationaliteit iets moet zijn dat
uiteindelijk wereldbetrokken is  er is een
neiging om goed te denken, zelfs onder zoals
ik vertelde zoals ik je liet zien onder uh in
belichaamde perioden met mensen van zeker
het moet in wezen een wereld zijn
, zoals acteren en oefenen
enzovoort
en perceptie natuurlijk, maar rationaliteit
blijft  zoiets als naturaliseerbare
notie iets dat niet kan worden
teruggebracht tot het niveau van het het
kan niet worden verkleind op een manier
zoals perceptie die kan worden verklaard
door een bepaalde dynamische betrokkenheid
enzovoort,
dus op dat moment dacht ik dat goed
misschien is dit
een knieprobleem, omdat
in andere
andere contexten wordt aangenomen dat
wat perceptie ook is, als het niet wordt
gearticuleerd op een manier om een
bepaalde pasvorm met professionele
combinatie te bieden, perceptie dan een gegeven is
en dit is de mythe van de gegeven
dimensie  in het begin en ik dacht
van wel, misschien is dit iets van
er is iets van een mythe van het
gegeven hier werken aan een actieve
cognitie maar dit is niet ik denk het  is
niet fataal, want we kunnen niet principieel
beweren dat in plaats van
de stapperceptie en
andere basisvormen van combinaties
met concepten en dergelijke te construeren, we misschien
vanuit de andere richting zouden kunnen redeneren, proberen
de rationaliteit te verlagen naar een meer niet-genaturaliseerd
niveau van
uh
dus dat was de motivatie en het was
erg, het was een lang beoordelingsproces en ik
geloof dat mijn eerste de eerste versie
van het papier de kijker erg was Ik
denk dat ze helemaal correct waren Ik
keurde de suggestie tenslotte goed, maar hij
was erg uh
ze  waren onvermurwbaar om dat
deel te nemen en ik denk dat het beter was,
want het is een andere literatuur, het
is een andere uh een heleboel referenties die
meestal niet in gesprek zijn met een
activisme en lichaamsherkenning en het was
erg moeilijk om gewoon de  in
dezelfde bewoordingen belangrijk om mijn argumenten naar voren te brengen,
dus het is iets dat ik heb uitgekrabd
en ik heb niet te veel over
dat systeem nagedacht, maar ik denk dat het iets is dat ik
zou willen  om op terug te komen en
misschien heeft iemand dat
de afgelopen jaren ook gedaan ik weet het niet ik
kan het me herinneren maar
deze relatie tussen een activisme de
mythe van het geschenk en het leek te zijn het
lijkt heel
duidelijk te zijn  dus het is ik denk dat iets dat
we zouden kunnen we moeten ik bedoel uh in staat zijn om te
verkennen, maar er is niet iets
dat in de voorgrond van de krant stond,
maar ik had het idee om over
rationaliteit te praten in alle opzichten
en tegelijkertijd  tijd ik las veel
over uh
noemde hem vanuit een filosofisch
perspectief natuurlijk ben ik niet
zo goed thuis in de technische aspecten
en de formaliteiten van de aanpak
maar ik was geïnteresseerd in de
filosofische consequenties daar en ik
dacht goed na  misschien is er iets om
hier te vergelijken, want zoals Clark's
citaat laat zien,
kun je helemaal over rationaliteit
praten en eh dat is iets dat ik
wilde ontwikkelen, maar niet in een cognitivistische kijk
maar niet radicaal belichaamde film dus
dat is de achtergrond
geweldig dank je zou je misschien kunnen
beschrijven wat de mythe van het
gegeven is wat was de context waarin die
mythe ontstond en waar gaan we heen nadat we
de mythe van het gegeven ter sprake hebben gebracht
want ik zag het als een concept dat  je
weefde in dus waar ging het over
oke dus het midden van het geven dat
goed er zijn verschillende mogelijke Givens,
afhankelijk van je smaak van filosofie
van mij, maar het meest klassiek in eerdere
gebieden van de geest neem de de
inhoud van de waarneming die moet worden gegeven  gebed
rationeel op een manier dat we bepaalde
input hebben die eh gewoon door de
geest wordt ontvangen en de geest interpreteert het zodat
verkopers verschillende verkopers beroemd zijn omdat
ze zijn uh dit probleem hebben beschreven als
een probleem, want niet alleen verhoogt het de brandstof
van de geest, maar ook  voor rationalisten,
maar aan de andere kant wordt rationeel
meestal uh rationele intuïtie als een
gegeven beschouwd, wat wil zeggen dat er een
bepaald niveau van cognitie is dat uh
onuitgesproken is dat het'  is gegeven of zoals sommige
mensen praten over gefokt zijn gegeven,
maar op een bepaalde manier is er dit niveau van
kennis dat wordt gegeven en de geest moet
het interpreteren, maar als het op
deze manier wordt gegeven, heeft het geen contactpunt geen
uh kruising tussen wat dan ook
wat de geest ook doet en dit
basisniveau van uh overheersing, dus mijn idee is
om de beschuldiging te vermijden dat je toegewijd bent
aan de mythe van het gegeven, maar nogmaals, dit
is niet iets dat expliciet is in
de nativistische literatuur, maar het is
iets dat lijkt te zijn  mogelijk om
te ontwikkelen in een
ik bedoel uh in dit soort vergelijking, maar
het is niet het is niet van de
niet duidelijk daar, maar
een manier om ze op te lossen voor de Givens
om te zeggen dat perceptuele inhoud
al conceptueel van aard is,
wat bijvoorbeeld is hoe Joe McDowell  doet in
gedachten hoe meer dat je weet een
perceptie uh de grap is komt met
ondertitels jij en interpreteert de wereld
zoals jij dat doet maar uh
ik denk dat dat op de een of andere manier is
om te demystificeren je kent een rationaliteit  en
de bovenste lagen van combinatie
proberen ze te bedenken uh uh in minder
uh inhoud voor analyse
zonder ze vast te leggen, dus het is strikt
genomen met een inhoudsniveau dat
gescheiden is van basisniveaus van
combinatie, dat is een manier waarop ik denk
dit te doen en  rationaliteit lijkt het
enige sleutelconcept te zijn om dit te doen,
omdat meestal wordt aangenomen dat het iets
uitsluitend menselijks is en iets dat
verband houdt met redeneren, en als dat
zo is, dan kan rationaliteit geen aanleiding geven tot actie
en als de actie natuurlijk
inhoudloos van aard is  dus als
rationaliteit een gevoel is dat in wezen tevreden is en
reactie in wezen onbevat is voor
inhoudloos, dan kun je dit niet hebben
uh dat heeft dit uh kruispunt
tussen twee domeinen gedaan en dit is
iets dat ik wilde vermijden, maar zoals ik
je vertelde, werd het zo moeilijk om
deze mening op een
voldoende duidelijke en algemene manier uitdrukken is
dat ik op aanbeveling van onze recensent
dat uitkrab en ik
denk er nog steeds aan  t maar niets ik
heb geen
goede argumentatie ontwikkeld die
het duidelijker behandelt dan ik kan doen zoals ik net deed
in zeer algemene bewoordingen
cool goed sommige woorden die je associeerde
met rationaliteit waren aanpassingsvermogen
en ook vaardigheid dus wat zie je
als de relatie van rationaliteit en
Fitness
als een biologische functie ja ja
oke ik eh
ik denk dat het een intrinsieke
relatie is echt ik denk dat het
uh waarschijnlijk de meest
[muziek]
um voor de
hand liggende consequentie is van rationeel handelen
op een speciale schaal en wanneer  we praten
over de vraag of rationaliteit een kenmerk is
van bepaalde soorten of in plaats van
individuen. Ik denk dat Fitness een van
de belangrijkste concepten is om dit te denken
als het resultaat van deze
uh rationele actie,
dus hoewel ik niet zeg dat ik dat niet doe
zet het in die zaken in de krant ik
denk dat het mogelijk is om het op die
manier te denken weet je zie het niet
als een bezwaar om te denken aan
rationaliteit maar nogmaals het is erg liberaal
en ik ben bereid om  o om deze consequentie ook te accepteren voor
elk levend
organisme op een bepaalde manier als het, als het nog niet
instinctief is gegaan, het op een manier is
aangepast aan zijn omgeving, dus ik ben bereid
om te zien dat het een minimaal
niveau van rationaliteit van  omgaan met uh
de vijand veranderende omgeving,
maar goed en het is de prijs van het hebben van een
zeer
uh
liberaal Progressieve notie van
rationaliteiten dit is een gevolg
daarvan geloof ik
dus je hebt gezegd dat fitness een
gevolg is van rationeel gedrag zijn
er andere consequenties of  hoe herkennen we
rationaliteit van buitenaf
anders dan alleen maar goed te zeggen dat de
mierenkolonie het goed doet, dus in de mate dat
het rationeel is, het is adaptief een
exposerende instantie en dat alles
is zo'n
deflatoir rationaliteitsconcept dat alle bestaande
dingen mensen en  anders worden er alleen maar door
beschreven of zijn er
uitkomsten die we kunnen gebruiken
om bijvoorbeeld een rationeel of
irrationeel gedrag te ontwarren van alleen de
gevolgen die door su worden weerspiegeld  rvival en
Fitness
goed Ik moest hier heel
goed over nadenken omdat ik
dit concept niet wil bagatelliseren op een manier
dat goed alles IPS is van feit of
rationeel door het feit dat het
leeft, het is een acteerrelatie, maar ik
denk dat uh in bepaalde gevallen
men de natie zou kunnen identificeren dat ik
gelijk ben aan de individuen
um zelfvoorziening in die niche dus dus
op het individuele niveau in het bijzonder
oke dit is een overtuigende bepaalde
acties die classifiers
irrationeel zouden kunnen maken in de mate dat ze  uh
zijn schadelijk voor met overleven, maar
uh op soortniveau is het
moeilijker om op die manier te argumenteren, omdat
om dit soort gedrag of gevolg te identificeren,
maar ik denk dat
om het idee van rationeel niet te bagatelliseren
en goed te zeggen alles wat is
leven is een factor die je zou moeten hebben
om dit soort specifieke handelingen te identificeren
die nadelig zijn
voor één overleving,
dus in het geval van de mierenkolonie
weet ik het misschien niet
het verwelkomen van indringers
zou het soort gedrag zijn dat
nadelig zou zijn voor het
overleven als zodanig
Ik weet het niet Ik weet niet of dit is eh
het is een onmogelijke manier
om hierover na te denken Ik moest helderder nadenken,
maar
mijn  zorgvuldig
oh heel interessant en je hebt
dat antwoord en in de presentatie ingebracht
als meerdere
geneste tijdschalen, net zoals Eco Evo
Devo doet vanuit een meer biologisch
perspectief, kijkend naar hoe Niche-
constructie de kloof overbrugt tussen
langzamere fylogenetische processen en
snellere ontwikkelingsprocessen
um zo  hoe verhoudt deze
ingebedde en meerschalige overweging zich
tot het
inhoudsconcept, zoals of inhoud wordt
gelokaliseerd in één lichaam of wordt de inhoud
verdeeld over entiteiten of is de
rationaliteit verdeeld over entiteiten
hoe zouden we zelfs de plaats
van rationaliteit identificeren en dat  roept ook een soort van beroep
op de um horizontale en modulaire
conceptie van het citaat dat u hebt
verstrekt, dus hoe identificeren we saillant
ruimtelijke tijdschalen en systemen van
belang
oh ah ik weet het niet ik weet niet of
ik dit volledig kan beantwoorden, maar het lijkt me
dat op het niveau van uh als we het hebben
over inhoud, bijvoorbeeld inhoud als een
nauwkeurigheid  voorwaarden voor symbolische
gedachten Ik denk dat we gelukkig moeten
zeggen dat het niet is gelokaliseerd in een
enkel individu, het is openbaar gedeeld,
dus je kunt zeggen dat
een gevolg hiervan is dat het
mogelijk is om verschillende redeneringspatronen te bedenken
die
informatiesites zijn geweest  op verschillende tijdstippen enz. en je kunt
zien dat ze verschillende niveaus hebben ontwikkeld
, verschillende uh-regels voor
inhoudsinformatie
en ik denk dat dit
aannemelijk is om te zeggen dat inhoud
gelokaliseerd is dat de
uh hoe kun je zeggen dat het de hoeveelheid is waarvan
je de details kent
alleen voor de rationaliteit denk ik dat
men
[muziek]
in bepaald gedrag zou kunnen identificeren
als het past bij deze uh
dit soort beschrijving van uh spin
bedreven vaardige interactie en
adaptief  interactie tussen een organisme
en zijn omgeving zijn niche dus
waarschijnlijk zouden we kunnen
we zouden hier verschillende antwoorden kunnen geven als
een rationaliteit en inhoud Ik ben bereid
te zeggen dat
inhoud voor organisatie niet
iets is dat in het hoofd gebeurt
iets dat er op een bepaalde manier is
de hoeveelheid anderen en dit is
iets dat de filosofie van mij
heeft tenminste sinds de jaren 60 de
filosofen van mij hebben gepleit
voor het idee dat inhoud extern
geïndividualiseerd is
en uh ik denk dat dit een van
de video's is van  bijvoorbeeld Hillary Putnam
en Tyler Burge en anderen dat de
mentale inhoud geïndividualiseerd is op
gemeenschapsniveau of maatschappelijk niveau,
maar anderzijds denken ze dat
rationaliteit in principe kan worden
geïndividualiseerd in bepaald gedrag, maar
het zou afhangen van de doelen van het individu
en de  de niche die het bewoont
, enzovoort,
er zijn hier natuurlijk actuele
variabelen die ook belangrijk kunnen
zijn om Gedrag te identificeren
als rationeel of niet
oké,
bedankt,
nou ja, een zin die me echt bijblijft
, was als weet hoe niet weet dat
misschien een basaal punt in je werk
en een focus op die actie, dus ik
wilde gewoon
horen hoe actie en oefening terwijl
je weefde  ze hier vandaag hoe worden die
termen aangesproken
en hoe zijn de dingen tegenwoordig anders met
de behandeling van actie en praktijk en
knowhow weet dat niet dan in de
helmholtzee in dagen of zelfs in oude
of in wereldkennistradities
Dus oké cool dus het idee  Ik
denk dat
er een tendens is van eh, het is een
tendens van een zeer moderne filosofie,
maar het is zeer invloedrijk geweest in de
eerste golf van cognitieve wetenschap
om perceptie te zien als
een vermogen om de omgeving te categoriseren
en een discrete  beschrijving van
milieuaspecten dus bijvoorbeeld
waarnemen dat uh de de de
dat ik weet dat de beker links van mij is, is
een kwestie van weten dat er
iets is met het zoeken naar dergelijke eigenschappen
mijn linkerzijde en dit is een soort van uh weet
dat een soort propositieve houding ten
opzichte van de wereld, dus
uh ik denk dat het ook het
interessante is van een activisme en
ecologische psychologie en in de
mate dat ze het Amerikaanse
pragmatisme herinneren vanaf het begin van  de
eeuw is om
perceptie te zien als een kwestie van het niet
categoriseren van deze geweldige eigenschappen in
de wereld, maar als het onthullen van
mogelijkheden om te handelen
en dit is iets dat als we dat zouden
uitleggen in termen van uh in epidemische
termen zoals kennis, we zouden'
ik zeg het niet als een kwestie van weten dat de bocht naar links van mij is, maar weten hoe ik de beker moet pakken en doen wat ik
ermee wil doen als ik een kopje koffie wil drinken
of als ik hem wil gebruiken als een
presse-papier het zal verschillende
stille eigenschappen hebben en dit is iets
dat,
hoewel het is geweest,
ik denk dat een activisme en ecologische
psychologie en andere belichaamde opvattingen over
cognitie grotendeels met succes
zijn veranderd  Als je deze discussie tot dit
punt brengt, denk ik dat je in de uh in meer
traditionele cognitieve wetenschappen nog
steeds het idee hebt dat organismen goed worden
waargenomen door
de manier waarop de omgeving te beschrijven,
dit is iets dat ik denk dat
meer traditionele lezingen van
voorspellende verwerking uh duidelijk maken
zoals in uh het idee dat je afleidt
over de bron van stimuli en niet
in uh en niet en dit is niet ik bedoel
dit is gemakkelijker ontvankelijk voor het idee
dat de hersenen of het cognitieve
systeem weten dat
de wereld is  zo en zo is
de omgeving zo en zo in plaats van te
zeggen dat het agendasysteem weet
hoe het met de wereld moet omgaan en ik geloof
dat
het het punt is
dat activisten en uh ecologische
psychologen proberen te maken is om
en ook te werken aan het voorspellende
codering en het principe van vrije energie
enz. is om aan te tonen dat deze begrippen deze
kaders een minimaal idee kunnen zijn dat
het kubernetes-systeem weet hoe het moet worden
betrokken  ge in de
omgeving op een manier dat het niet hoeft te
worden gelezen in de samenvatting aan boord
dat het Kindle-systeem afleidt
dat de wereld zo is, dus ik denk dat dit
een manier is om het uit te leggen, maar ook uh
filosofisch als je een groot aan
het begin van  de laatste
decennia euh een gigantische discussie over
of er geen Cloud gereduceerd zou kunnen worden om
dat te weten en dan heb je een
achtergrond van dit en ander
als een onafhankelijk idee van je weet
dat en of je
de een tot de ander zou kunnen reduceren enzovoort  dus
ik denk dat het daar niet stopt, je kunt niet
uh ook al kan ik een claim indienen voor
perceptie van een ander, wetende hoe
ze nog steeds de achtergrondkwestie zijn
of knowhow kan worden behandeld als
en dat alles in
ieder geval dit is iets dat  Ik ben ook
bezig met de laatste tijd,
er is veel te zeggen, het is
zo'n interessant idee, vooral met
linguïstische communicatie, het is een
beetje zoals de vinger en de maan en
praten over de maan, maar de vinger is
alleen  waar het is en we hebben het niet
over de pointer we hebben het over
de referentie
en dus om
een ​​sociocognitieve vorm van communicatie
te gebruiken in gecultiveerde taal
of in geschreven academisch discours om daar
doorheen te kijken of dat opnieuw te bedenken
en zelfs te zien wat lijkt  om als het
toppunt van weten dat te zijn
en het nog steeds te zien als weten hoe
ik denk dat de vraag daar is
hoe lezen we kranten
ja natuurlijk ja ik denk dat het is uh het is
een
uh het is ja de waarden die het lijkt te
kunnen zijn  een heel groot probleem, want als
we proberen om deze negatieve
capaciteiten, zoals u zei, als een kwestie
van knowhow te behandelen
, lijkt het erop dat we nog steeds iets missen
over bijvoorbeeld communicatie en aan
de andere kant denk ik en dit is mijn
intuïtie, maar ik denk dat  dat we in
principe zouden kunnen praten over
hoe
begrijpen wat je zojuist hebt gezegd en
proberen erop te reageren een kwestie is van
weten hoe je je taalkundig moet gedragen,
maar ik denk dat zelfs deze beweging
om hoge niveaus van cognitionisten te behandelen,
waardoor ik  t een kwestie van knowhow het
laat nog steeds iets weg waar
ik in ben ik bedoel persoonlijk ik ben
en er blij mee ik denk dat we op een bepaald
niveau dat moeten zeggen goed dat is
een ander soort benadering die hier nodig
is om uit te leggen hoe we  communiceer bijvoorbeeld
heel adequaat om niet te zeggen dat het
niet en nu is, maar het is niet alleen
dat ik denk dat er in ieder geval meer dan
praktische kennis nodig is,
maar misschien is de sleutel hier om te denken aan
praktische kennis die gewoon basis en
noodzakelijk is voor andere soorten  van andere andere
soorten kennis die ze nodig hebben
om deel te nemen aan dit soort uitwisseling
misschien is dit misschien een laag,
ik weet zeker dat hier
meer over moet worden
gezegd om een ​​meer
informatief antwoord te geven, maar dit is een bij
mijn huidige standpunt is in ieder geval dat
geen enkele manier de basis vormt voor onze
betrokkenheid bij de wereld en met
anderen, maar op een bepaald moment moeten we
in staat zijn om andere soorten
begrip te ontwikkelen om
de complexe soorten van uh uit te leggen.  uitwisselingen die
we in ons dagelijks leven hebben
, zoals het lezen van kranten zoals je zei
Ik ben het ermee eens Ik denk dat
framing weet dat als basis en dan het
herstellen van knowhow een uitdaging is en
het is ook een uitdaging om te beginnen met de
basale cognitieve processen als worden
uitgevoerd zonder huis en  om die
stukjes knowhow opnieuw samen te brengen in de wetenschap
dat het niet per se een eenvoudige
uitdaging is, maar dat we liever
de uitdaging aangaan om symbolische
proposities declaratieve verbale
Etc cognitieve processen te assembleren vanuit een meer
liminale
ecologische cognitieve benadering
of proberen het ecologische te herstellen van
de turing  machine in zekere zin, dus het
lijkt alsof
u spreekt ter ondersteuning van het funderen
in ecologisch plausibele basale cognitieve
processen en dan werken aan het
samenstellen van de wolkenkrabber
ja ja ja helemaal ja ik denk dat het
goed is
beide uh
die beide benaderingen zijn moeilijk
te monteren  zoals je zei om
dit soort uitleg te geven, ofwel
linksonder of van bovenaf, maar ik  sta
natuurlijk gunstiger tegenover de
webbenadering ik denk dat het ook om een ​​andere
reden lijkt het
uitgangspunt lijkt
een biologische beschrijving te zijn van hoe we
met de wereld omgaan en
andersom lijkt het veel
moeilijker  om uit te leggen uh hoe we komen
met deze uh biologische vragen
zoals onze lichaamsmorfologie en zo lijkt het
dat we daar eerst rekening mee moeten houden
en dan komen we bij de andere
vragen die ook moeilijk te
beantwoorden zijn, maar op het allerlaatste moment  tenminste, ik denk
dat het
een bottom-up benadering is die meer uh
integratief is, in zekere zin is de
kans groot dat het meer
in ons voordeel lijkt te zijn in de zin
en en de manier waarop je het een beetje
inkadert, deed me denken dat als je
om een ​​computer helemaal opnieuw
te programmeren, kan het een abstracte of een virtuele
computer zijn, dus het hoeft niet eens
een specifieke uitvoering te hebben
en in die situatie kan men zich
bezighouden met het assembleren,
weten dat beweren dat en het samenstellen van
deze verklaren  atieve
uitspraken en logische processen in
iets dat dynamischer is of in
interactie is met de omgeving, maar
dat proces van zoals full-stack
engineering
met logica en siliconen aan de basis
is heel anders dan hoe we hier zijn gekomen
en dus zou het kunnen, maar het is
gratis
um goed  je gaf een beetje inzicht
in eh ik denk de voor, tijdens en
na van peer review, dus ik was gewoon
nieuwsgierig wat er
veranderde tijdens en na de paper zoals
in de afgelopen maanden of jaren of hoe
lang het ook was, hoe ben je hierin geëvolueerd
en wat dan  zie je als relevante
vervolgstappen, of ze nu voor jou zijn of
gewoon uit te voeren zijn zijn we op zoek
naar een hersenmeting zijn we op zoek
naar een videocamera in een bos zijn we op
zoek naar een conceptueel vooruitgang wat
gaat er verder voorbij  uw
ontwikkelingen
dat is dat is een goede vraag ik denk
eh
ik ben niet helemaal tevreden met de
manier waarop ik ik zal gebruiken buitenlands niveau ik weet niet
of dit een van deze zou worden
uitgevoerd ou  t in uh ik weet eerlijk gezegd niet
of je het in principe in
andere empirische termen zou kunnen uitvoeren maar
eh ik zeg niet dat eh
nou ja ik zou het vandaag een beetje
anders schrijven niet dat het uh niet is
dat ik het niet eens ben met de  papier
oorspronkelijk, maar ik denk dat
er iets is dat ik
zou willen herformuleren, maar ze geven ook geen
toestemming uh ik denk dat hij een nieuw
papier had,
maar misschien in de toekomst, maar dit is
iets dat
de vragen zoals de mythe hebben
gegeven die is  nog steeds de filosofische
vraag
en de conceptuele, ze houden me nog steeds bezig
, maar ik moet nog
de mogelijkheid vinden om deze
ideeën zorgvuldiger te ontwikkelen en het algemene
beeld dat ik daar naar voren breng Ik denk dat ik denk
dat het nog steeds staat
uh maar
eh
ik zou graag ik ik  ik wacht nog steeds op
deze kans om het verder uit te werken en te
zien hoe ver ik kan komen maar ik weet het nog
niet ik moet toegeven dat ik niet weet wat
de toekomstige ontwikkelingen van dit idee zijn
maar eh ik heb gewerkt  op verschillende
geïsoleerde
problemen
Ik heb de afgelopen jaren aan deze benadering gewerkt. Ik heb gewerkt met
het begrip informatie en wetenschappelijk
begrip en informatie voor
ecologische en activisten van
combinatie en recentelijk werk ik
meer recentelijk met een paar hogescholen aan
virtual reality en perceptieherkenning,
dus uh
dit  is hoe ik mijn
onderzoek graag doe om interessante
uh-vragen te vinden en te zien hoe ik ermee om kan gaan
, maar niet per se dat
ik op
die manier gebonden ben aan één redenering, dus dit
is wat er gebeurde op het moment dat ik
werkte met  rationaliteit als ik dacht dat
het een heel cool onderwerp was en uh ik denk nog steeds
dat het is, maar ik heb geen tijd gehad
om terug te komen en opnieuw te formuleren wat ik
wilde, maar uh misschien misschien ergens in de
nabije toekomst Ik weet het niet, maar meer  het
meest recente waar ik aan heb gewerkt,
heeft niets te maken met cellulaire
rationaliteit, maar ik denk dat sommige producten
verkeerd kunnen zijn, namelijk die van een
virtuele realiteit en
hoe verhoudt de visuele realiteit zich eigenlijk
tot com  binatie
omdat er duidelijk iets ontbreekt
aan een doorzettingsvermogen en een visuele
omgeving,
dat is natuurlijk zo, als ik iemand
ben, bijvoorbeeld als ik in een visuele
omgeving ben waar ik onder een soort
bedreiging sta, kan ik iets voelen dat analoog is aan
angst, maar  Ik vrees niet echt voor mijn
leven
en stel me voor dat de persoon op de
virtuele realiteit zo rationeel is om
weg te rennen van
de dreiging de virtuele dreiging
enzovoort, dit is dit de dit is
wat ik werk  aan en uh misschien is
het een punt om terug te keren naar
dit idee van radicale en actieve
rationaliteit en in feite uh de krant is
net geaccepteerd, dus zoals ik je al
zei voordat ik het zo druk had de afgelopen
dagen omdat we bewijzen aan het corrigeren waren
mijn  collega's en ik nooit figuurlijk
uh en ik had
de afgelopen weken ook een strak schema om de gecorrigeerde versie van het papier in te dienen en toen
kreeg ik de bewijzen en
oh
uh nou misschien uh in de toekomst kan
ik terugkomen op het iss
ik zou het wel willen maar ik weet niet of ik ik
weet het niet ik kan de ontwikkelingen daarvan echt niet voorzien
maar uh in het algemeen ben ik het
nog steeds eens met mijn oorspronkelijke idee maar
ik zal het een beetje anders formuleren  beetje
dus het VR-punt Ik weet zeker dat er nog
veel meer te zeggen is, maar het deed me denken
aan alleen de titel virtual reality het is een
virtualisatie en dus op dezelfde manier
waarop
cognitieve actieplanning
ons in staat stelt om beleid te
voeren dat ons lichaam niet doet'  t nemen
al was het maar om ze te evalueren en er
tegen te kiezen, maar we kunnen op een vlucht
van fantasie gaan hebben een grillig beleid
selectieproces
van counterfactuals
mentaal,
maar dan is onze morfologie een beetje zoals
onze levenslijn weet je als je
echt van een richel valt, dan is het  gaat pijn doen
en dan ben je in virtual reality
belichaamd
perceptuele ervaring is letterlijk
een virtualisatie van
overlevingskritieke situaties, dus je
zou jezelf kunnen zien als op een richel,
maar je bent op een vlakke vloer
en dan in die situatie
als je een soort
cognitieve waarnemer bent buiten de
videogame, zou je kunnen zeggen dat het
rationeel voor mij is om er gewoon af te vallen om te zien
wat er gebeurt,
dus dat is zo, maar dan is er een laag
van rationaliteit in de ruimte ja, zoals
wat een goede zet is  in de game
eh en dus vervaagt de lijn
tussen
[muziek]
het is het vervaagt de kriticiteit van
het lichaam en eh
ik weet zeker dat je hier veel meer over hebt nagedacht,
dus hoe speelt dit in op onze
virtual reality
eh met de  manieren waarop we denken over en
deze systemen goed gebruiken en ontwerpen
dit is de de de de de
vragen die ons motiveerden om een ​​paper te schrijven
en uh NADA gaf ze en ik was
dat je in de technische literatuur ziet
dat veel onderzoekers werken met
de  uh behandel uh visuele waarneming als
illustri een soort illusie, maar daar hadden we
een beetje last van omdat het aan de
andere kant alleen in VR werkt omdat
we de apparaten belichaamden apparaten die
ze voor ons werken je hebt de controllers je
hebt het hoofd  ingesteld
en uh het lijkt zo raar om te zeggen dat de
gebruiker de gebruiker onder een soort
illusie is
en aan de andere kant lijkt het erop dat het
niet echt cognitie is, want zoals je
zei, er is geen biologische
relevantie voor die uh cognitieve
Zegt bij wijze van spreken als ik bijvoorbeeld
een appel in VR zie, het is niet
voedzaam, maar het is logisch in het
spel, maar de verschillende, eh
nou ja, ik heb een appel ontvangen in een in een
echte omgeving, het biedt
voeding  het is iets dat ik kan eten,
maar niet in VR Ik kan doen alsof dus we
bedachten dit uh concept van toespeling op
zijn vlak
uh het is alsof we
geconfronteerd worden met een echt dier maar het omvat
ook deze wil om te spelen dit idee
dat we niet zijn
misleid worden omdat we de
apparatuur aantrekken waarvan we weten dat we in het spel zitten en
dit is volgens mij een actueel onderwerp
omdat er metaforen zijn en ik ben erg
sceptisch over wat
dat ook kan mensen zijn erg optimistisch, maar
over de mogelijkheden van de metave  rse
en sommige auteurs denken echt dat
we strikt genomen in een simulatie zouden kunnen zitten,
maar ik bedoel, de beste
technologie die de huidige technologie
ons laat zien, is dat deze zeer beperkt is en dat je kunt
doen alsof je in een bepaalde omgeving
bent, enzovoort en dit denk ik  kan
een nieuwe manier van
denken over rationaliteit in deze
visuele omgeving bieden, op een manier dat
Russen misschien iets doen dat de omgeving
heeft gezegd om van de richel te springen en te zien
wat er gebeurt en aan de andere
kant gedragsaspecten ervan, soms
voelen mensen zich echt  angst en mensen
gaan de straat op voor fobieën met virtuele
realiteiten
en
eh, het is veel, er zijn veel
interessante vragen die
ik misschien bedoel voor toekomstig onderzoek, we kunnen er
ja op terugkomen, het deed me nadenken over
hoe de Apple in het echte leven is  het kan
calorieën voor je zijn maar het kan ook
calorieën zijn voor een vlieg het kan worden gegooid
je zou het als een hamer kunnen gebruiken je zou
het goed kunnen schilderen dus
ecologie en de generatieve  proces, zoals
we zouden zeggen, een soort actieve inferentie
gaat altijd verder dan de mogelijkheden
die
voor een bepaald object zijn geprogrammeerd en dan ook
het huidige discours over VR richt zich
sterk op headsets,
gewoon volledig anekdotisch sprekend,
niet mijn expertisegebied,
het lijkt een  beetje interessant
het is alsof de discussie over de mobiele telefoon
alleen gericht was op
rechthoeken van een bepaalde grootte,
wat dit geen virtuele realiteit maakt, het is
alsof je door een raam kijkt en
er is een andere kerel om mee te praten, dus
het is niet aan mijn hoofd gehecht
hebben een aantal van de motion tracking
um-capaciteiten die sommige technologieën
hebben, maar het is
een niche-modificatie in de persoonlijke
ruimte van Perry
en we kunnen
signalen en voordelen naar elkaar pushen,
dus een VR-frame of eigenlijk alleen een
frame van rationaliteit en perceptie-
cognitie-actie Cycli
die
zijn niet alleen beperkt tot één specifieke
realisatie of hardwaretype en kunnen
het hele gamma doorlopen van Total offline
persoon in een veld
tot s  iemand die erg
in The Matrix zit,
lijkt behoorlijk relevant, anders zullen nieuwe
technologieën, zelfs kleine varianten en
software-updates, gewoon
oneindig blijven verrassen en verwarren
ja, ik denk dat het een is, het is moeilijk om
de grenzen te definiëren
Ik bedoel, we zijn hier uh in een uitwisseling
die  Ik denk dat het zou kunnen toenemen, maar het kan worden
geclassificeerd als een vorm van virtual
reality natuurlijk, ik zie dat je je C-
geest
verpest, maar uh ik bedoel de meeste, ik denk dat het werkt,
tegenwoordig vinden ze het een doc door te
zeggen dat ze een headset moeten hebben  en
soms een controller, maar anders
dan dat klinkt virtual reality, maar
ja, het is moeilijk om iets te definiëren.
een
telefoon die gewoon aan de telefoon was of een
telegraaf in die tijd zou
het op die interface zijn geweest met die zintuiglijke
modaliteit en met die voorzieningen
is het  de virtualisatie
ja waartoe we toegang hebben van een
ander hoofdstuk vandaag
ja ik denk het wel ja een deel van onze paper
was om te beweren dat op een bepaalde manier de belichaming van
technologische apparaten
duidelijk nodig is niet dat is niet nieuw het is het
kenmerk van mens zijn
het is  het belichamen van technologische apparaten
wat ons heeft gemaakt tot wat we zijn sinds het
begin met behulp van analytische technologie en
het feit dat we het zo bekwaam kunnen belichamen
een apparaat zelfs als het is
geprogrammeerd om bijvoorbeeld in
virtual reality iets te hebben een
wezen waarmee je ons rijker kunt besturen  nieuwe
morfologie een andere morfologie
bijvoorbeeld zelfs als dat het geval is het
gebeurt alleen zo vakkundig omdat we
het apparaat kunnen belichamen sommige
experimenten hebben aangetoond dat je
bijvoorbeeld een draai van je pols kunt toewijzen aan een
derde arm
uh die individuele realiteit gaat van was
dat van je borst en mensen kunnen
leren om deze derde arm te besturen die
niet in onze werkelijke morfologie past,
maar het kan zo worden gemaakt door een Twist o  voor de
pols, dus
dit is iets dat we in
onze paper zullen bespreken. Nou,
je kunt dat alleen doen omdat je
het apparaat belichaamt, je kunt zien dat het een
illusie is.
zou die kant op gaan ik bedoel ik weet dat het
het onderscheid tussen virtuele
en niet-virtuele toppen vervaagt Ik denk dat dat een
manier is om met dit
cool om te gaan.
ik wil je bedanken voor de
gelegenheid om dit artikel te bespreken, het was
erg leuk voor mij ik heb er echt van genoten
en dit is een uh erg mooie en uh
comfortabele omgeving om deze problemen te bespreken
en denk nogmaals
bedankt ja geweldige discussie en
belangrijke onderwerpen en  we zullen graag weer met
je praten op elk moment
oke bedankt vaarwel bedankt